and finally new rule I know it's
supposed to be that magical time of year
but maybe what we all really need right
now is a good dose of realism I see a
lot of nativity scenes when I'm out as
you always do before Christmas and I
can't help thinking about where that
manger really is it's in the West Bank
on Palestinian land controlled by the
Palestinian Authority in 1950 the little
town of Bethlehem was 86% Christian now
it's overwhelmingly Muslim and that's my
point tonight things change to 2.3
billion Christians there can be no more
sacred site than where their savior was
born but they don't have it anymore and
yet no Crusader Army has geared up to
take it back things change countries
boundaries Empires Palestine was under
the Ottoman Empire for 400 years but
today an ottoman is something you put
under your
feet
the uh city of Byzantium became the city
of Constantinople became Istanbul not
everybody liked it but you can't keep
arguing the call Forever the Irish had
the entire Island to themselves but the
British were starting an Empire and well
the Irish lost their
tip they
uh they blew each other up over for 30
years but eventually everybody comes to
an accommodation except the
Palestinians was it unjust that even a
single Arab family was forced to move
upon the founding of the Jewish State
yes but it's also not rare happening all
through history all over the world and
mostly what people do is make the best
of it after World War II 12 million
ethnic Germans got shoved out of Russia
and Poland and Czechoslovakia because
being German had become kind of UNP
popular a million Greeks were shoved out
of turkey in 1923 a million ghanians out
of Nigeria in 1983 almost a million
French out of Algeria in 1962 nearly a
million Syrian refugees moved to Germany
8 years ago was that a perfect
fit and no one knows more about being
pushed off land than the Jews including
being almost wholly kicked out of every
Arab country they once lived in yes TI
Tock fans
ethnic ethnic cleansing happened both
ways in feder on the roof the family is
always moving to stay one step ahead of
the cacs but they deal with it when
they're leaving anatevka they say hey it
wasn't so great
anyway come on like other countries
don't have roofs you could fiddle
on
now now that's not how they really felt
but they were coping they coped because
sometimes that's all you can do history
is brutal and humans are not good people
history is sad and full of wrongs but
you can't make them unhappen because a
paraglider isn't a time
machine people get moved and yes colon
nobody was a bigger colonizer than the
Muslim Army that swept out of the
Arabian Desert and took over much of the
world in a single century and they
didn't do it by asking there's a reason
Saudi Arabia's flag is a sword Kosovo
was the Cradle of Christian Serbia then
it became Muslim they fought a war about
it in the 90s but stopped they didn't
keep it going for 75 years there were
deals on the table to share the land
called Palestine in 19 1947 993
95 98 2000 2008 and East Jerusalem could
have been the capital of a Palestinian
state that today might look more like
Dubai than Gaza arat was offered 95% of
the West Bank and said no the
Palestinian people should know your
leaders and the useful idiots on college
campuses who are their allies are not
doing you any favors by keeping alive
The River To The Sea myth I mean where
do you think Israel is going spoiler
alert
nowhere it's one of the most powerful
countries in the world with the $500
billion doll economy the world's second
largest tech sector after Silicon Valley
and nuclear weapons they're here they
like their bagel with a shmear get used
to do
it what's happening to Palestinians
today is horrible and not just in Gaza
in the West Bank too but Wars end with
negotiation and what the media glosses
over is it's hard to negotiate when the
other side's bargaining position is you
all die and disappear I mean the chant
from The River To The Sea yeah let's
look at the map here's the river here's
the sea oh I see it means you get all of
it not just the West Bank which was
basically the original un partition deal
you rejected because you wanted all of
it and always have even though it's
indisputably also the Jews ancestral
Homeland and so you attacked and lost
and attacked again and lost and attacked
again and lost as my friend Dr Phil says
how's that working for you
look at what Mexico used to own all the
way up to the top of California but no
Mexican is out there chanting from the
Rio Grand to Portland
Oregon because they chose a different
path they got real and built a country
that's the world's 14th biggest economy
now because they knew the United States
wasn't going to give back Phoenix any
more than Hamas will ever be in Tel
Aviv one of the leaders of Hamas says
save yourselves time and imaginary
dreams in a few years Allah willing you
will have to discuss the situation in
the region after Israel
I'm sorry who's the one with imaginary
dreams if I give you the benefit of the
doubt and say your plan for a completely
jewelist Palestine isn't that all the
Jews should
die what is the only other option they
move you move all the Jews okay I got to
warn you there's going to be some
ketching you move all the Jews and we do
this with what a fleet of trucks called
Jew
hul and to where are we moving this
entire country
Texas sure they have room and I guess we
could put the whing wall on the border
and kill two birds with one
stone or we could just get
serious